ramenez la coupe à la maison c'était
l'objectif de ces 40 équipes de handball
présente pendant deux jours au Palais
des Sports d'Élancourt les clubs du
département se sont réunis à l'occasion
des coupes et challenge des Yvelines
rendez-vous organisé tous les ans par le
comité de handball c'est les finales des
coupes voilà donc
l'événement concernait toutes les
catégories des moins de 11 ans au senior
pour remporter la compétition ils se
sont tous entraînés pour être près le
jour J à Élancourt on a commencé par
faire
la
défense et puis après l'attaque et voilà
tant que je peux je viens et même si je
suis malade bah je viens quand même une
compétition qui s'est déroulée dans une
belle ambiance devant plusieurs dizaines
de spectateurs venus garnir ce palais
des sports d'Élancourt une belle
récompense pour les handballeurs
handbaleuses
parmi les principaux résultats chez les
U18 féminines challenge Les Mureaux
longtemps porté face à l'Entente le PEC
Saint-Germain rendez-vous l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition dans
les usines
[Musique]